welcome back everybody our next guest is
a board-certified plastic surgeon in
beverly hills california
and the creator of the true curve
brazilian butt lift
and body contouring technique perfect
timing as we all want to look and feel
our best as the weather gets warmer
right here
in vegas let's welcome dr dos to the
show hi
hi thanks for having me on of course of
course i understand that the true curve
results is
dramatic they're dramatic results but
very natural looking right
that's correct now i i created the true
curve brazilian butt lift to really
sculpt the entire body and create
beautiful proportions for
each woman um doing his liposuction of
the midsection
to create a really tiny waist then i
transfer the fat
to the buttock to reshape it and sculpt
it into a beautiful shape i fill in the
the hips on the sides to get rid of the
indentions oh wow
the result is a beautifully dramatic
figure
that looks very feminine very natural
and i'm so impressed by the video you're
showing
yeah so mike uh i'm sorry the video yeah
there's a video of one of
one of your we're showing a video of one
of your buttons
looks great yeah as you can see it's
it's beautiful it's dramatic yet the
shape is very natural
and you know my philosophy is not it's
not just about the buttock but really
sculpting the entire body
to create beautiful proportions and
who's a good candidate for the true
curve brazilian butt lift or the body
contouring
great question you know is i mean it's
an excellent procedure for
anyone that has a little extra stubborn
fat around the mid section
which you know is a lot of us right
problem areas and what about patients
most frequently
you know as services what are they
asking for
well i i you know even during this time
of the pandemic as it's resolving
you know we're still seeing a huge
demand for the brazilian butt lifts
body contouring and pretty much a lot of
the cosmetic procedures that we perform
including breast augmentation tummy
tucks the necklace
see the nand has still been really high
for body contouring and it's been great
and the patients really love it and dr
dos i thought
i saw a few photos of before and after
of the necklace let's talk about that
describe
the technique and what that does for
people
absolutely the mini necklift is a great
procedure to really contour and define
the neck and jaw
line and the result is really again very
dramatically beautiful it creates more
youthfulness
and beauty in fact i see a lot of
younger patients coming to me even in
their 20s and 30s
to get more definition along their chin
now what i'm doing is liposuction
just to get rid of that little double
chin there even the smallest amount it
makes a huge difference in the face
and then i use a laser under the skin to
tighten the skin so that way that
lays down very beautifully and like i
said the results are
are beautiful well i the proof is right
there on the screen your photo your
before and after photos are great so
thank you so much for sharing this
information
thank you yeah i get uh you know i get a
lot of patients from
even the vegas area coming out to
beverly hills yeah and actually
it's from all over the country because
again the demand is great and they love
the results
um yeah it's it's a great procedure
yeah and who wouldn't want a little trip
to beverly hills thank you so much dr
das
all right for more information visit
dosmd.com or just call 1-855-496-4646
you can also check them out on instagram
it's just at dennis das
md las vegas now